okay so we have our e to the X right I
introduced chain rule and I showed you
how it work I don't chain will work here
okay
all right let's have a think about this
you could introduce your new
substitution in that kind of thing and
you could prove the result but I think
you guys are pretty good by now let's
see if we can do this on the board
without after you and all that kind of
thing you have two different the inside
and the outside
right what's the inside function to X so
it's derivative is 2 there's my inside
derivative I multiplied by the outside
derivative right the outside root is 1
over what have you gotten there
okay which is 2x X inside outside oh
hold on a second
to ever 2 X what's going on what's
happened what's gone wrong has anything
gone wrong
who thinks something's wrong wrong who
thinks we've differentiated incorrectly
so who thinks you've differentiated but
yeah no yeah yeah not sure what's going
on let me ask this question
instead login to X right
how does it look different to want e to
the X those questions if I put log
videos ok a value like say if this is
natural log right when y equals 0 Y to 0
what's X equal to e correct because
either way taking another one no sorry
there yeah that's better all right cuz
that's it's the exponential one lives on
that's right
that's one ok now if I compare that to
say log off to X ok and I say where's
the intercept for log of 2x ok this is
our log
okay so 2x is equal to e to the power 0
which is 1 do you like up
it's a different spot okay so you're
like it's it's a half there and you can
plot few more points for what you get is
this kind of [ __ ] ok and that's it a
half hmm what's going on this is mean if
I put let's let's see how well I drew it
if I if I were to put a vertical line
across here right and compare what is
the gradient at any given point along
this graph ok
I think what you would find it is the
gradient is actually between these two
graphs it's always the same what's the
difference
once can moved once been pushed upwards
has actually moved left to right you
know why I know it hasn't moved left
alright where's the acetone there's an
acetone here right
the acetone is that at x equals zero
okay the asymptote is at x equals zero
for this function but it's also an x
equals zero for this function so I
haven't moved left or right at all I'll
just move up and down okay so this is
like looking at you know if you looked
at X square and you're differentiating
you get a derivative okay then if you
looked at x squared plus 1 or x squared
plus 2 or x squared plus 50 million okay
you differentiate them what happens to
the constant the advantages because they
all have the same derivative they're all
2x okay in exactly the same way because
these graphs are sitting on top of each
other and I couldn't add in log of 3x
and lower for X a lot of 5x they all
have the same derivative okay that's
weird
all right let's try another one come on
I didn't draw that carefully let's try
the derivative all unless not writing
log base E okay so I'm just gonna write
natural log
I'll say X square X square now things
start to get a bit different chain
differentiate the inside differentiate
the outside what's the inside when I
differentiate it I'll get to where I
differentiate the outside it's 1 over
whatever you've got there right so 1
over X or square okay so now I've got 2
over X
hold on if you remember your log laws
you should have anticipated that right
because think about this guy all right
remember your log laws that to that
power is really just the coefficient is
it not you bring the two from up there
bringing out the front so of course we
need differentiate this it should be two
times whatever that was which is 2 times
1 over X okay my brain is melting all
right now that's the basic idea
okay but as you can see because I'm
adding all these different kinds of
functions they can combine in what's
more different ways okay does it feel
like you know you got more elements you
can make more different action
substances and materials form because
you can have more combinations